les chars allemands sur les champs de
bataille
un dimanche après midi d'été au sud de
l'angleterre
une démonstration de chars et de
véhicules blindés attire les foules
des passionnés de véhicules militaires
et un public fasciné prennent grand
plaisir à observer ces engins d'il ya 50
ans
tout le monde s'amuse des tours dans ces
véhicules sont organisées et les chars
une fois encore font trembler le sol
dans ce cadre tranquille il est facile
d'oublier que ces engins furent à leur
époque les machines de mort du plus
terrible conflit de l'humanité
les réalité brutale du champ de bataille
peuvent révéler les pires aspects de
l'ingéniosité humaine
les plus brillants esprits scientifiques
ingénieurs sont utilisés dans les plus
noirs desseins imaginer de nouveaux
moyens de tuer mutiler ont terrifié leur
ennemi le moindre avantage est
implacablement exploité dans l'espoir de
garantir la victoire finale
parfois la peur elle-même est suffisante
pour vaincre l'ennemi
ce fut certainement le cas avec les
chars lance flammes
ces armes est effrayante étaient des
chars dont le canon avait été remplacé
par un lance-flammes capable de tirer un
jet de napalm jusqu'à 45 m
il n'était pas particulièrement précis
ni même très efficace mais les deux
camps l'avait utilisé lors de la
première guerre mondiale
ils furent conçues pour déloger
l'infanterie de ses retranchements et
bunkers mais leur arme principale
restait la peur le lance-flammes
projetait une mixture inflammable
contenu dans un réservoir de 100 litres
qui permettait de lancer 80 j'ai d'une
durée de deux secondes
mais rien d'autre qu'un char comparable
à n'importe quel char est la raison pour
laquelle il ressembler aux autres chars
et et qu'il ne devait pas être repérés
sur le champ de bataille est
reconnaissable lorsqu'on transportait à
son bord une pleine charge de napalm
n'était pas une bonne chose
je pense que la meilleure utilisation du
lance-flammes füssel faites par les
marines américains dans le pacifique
les japonais retranchés dans leur
défense entend inverser était
inexpugnable est décidée à résister le
seul moyen d'en venir à bout et et le
lance flammes
et si on pouvait mettre se lance flammes
derrière un bandage alors tant mieux
pour les fantassins tapis dans leurs
trous de combat même le plus petit char
était doté d'une aura d'invincibilité
s'avançant implacablement vers eux
il ressemblait à un mastodonte blindés
l'essence même de l'armé blindée
il semblait si un vulnérables et
mécanique qu'il était facile d'oublier
qu'à l'intérieur il y avait des êtres
humains avec les mêmes peurs et émotions
font sens surtout soldats présents sur
le champ de bataille
sous bien des aspects ses émotions et
est accrue par le fait que même si le
char offrait la protection de son
blindage il imposait bien des
contraintes à ses occupants
dans le char la visibilité était
sérieusement limitée et l'intérieur
exigu et bruyant
l'équipage était parfaitement conscient
que son engin était une cible
prioritaire pour toute arme et demi sur
le terrain
avec ses propres réserves de carburant
et de munitions embarqué il savait que
le moindre impact pouvait transformer
l'habitacle en enfer
il y avait aussi le risque que les
fantassins ennemis se trouve
suffisamment proche pour attaquer avec
des armes antichars
depuis des positions cachées le danger
pour les équipages sur le champ de
bataille venaient principalement du
manque de visibilité depuis l'intérieur
du ch a imaginé un champ de vision
réduit à une petite zone vers l'avant ce
complété par quelques autres répartis
autour du véhicule mais toujours
entrecoupé d'angles morts la plupart des
engins blindés de cette époque
n'avançait pas beaucoup plus vite qu'un
homme à pied et un fantassin armée de
n'importe quelle arme antichar pouvez
facilement courir et trouver une
position de tir à n'importe quelle phase
de la bataille
dans des circonstances favorables en
bonne position leur solide blindage
frontale faisant face à l'ennemi
les équipages de chars allemands de la
seconde guerre mondiale pouvait se
sentir en confiance
c'est panzer des dernières années de la
guerre pouvait encaisser les coups de la
plupart des canons antichars de l'époque
à presque toutes les distances de combat
excepté à bout portant
c'est l'énorme gac tiger qui fut déployé
en 1945 il porte toujours les marques de
la bataille on peut clairement voir sur
ce véhicule survivants où les obus
alliés ont touché sans réussir à
perforer le blindage
lorsque les équipes d'infanterie
antichar réussissait à s'approcher ou
que les chars ennemis étaient en mesure
de manoeuvrer pour frapper sur les côtés
ou l'arrière plus fragiles la situation
bascule est dramatiquement
les blindés conquérant se transformer en
cercueil d'acier
les pilotes de ces chars américains ont
également un bon champ de vision du
moment qu'ils gardent leur tête exposé
hors du véhicule
lorsque le chef de char se tenait hors
de la trappe de sa tourelle lui aussi
jouissait d'une excellente visibilité du
champ de bataille mais lorsque les
balles commençait à siffler le chef de
char et le pilote devait se retirer à
l'intérieur de l'habitacle
refermant les trappes derrière eux
une fois le ch a refermé l'équipage
n'avait plus qu'une perception très
limitée du monde extérieur
leur moteur diesel ronronnant leurs
armes faisant feu la chaleur générée à
l'intérieur du char et est oppressante
au combat le bruit l'odeur de
transpiration de fumée de peur et de
corps dit sont à peine imaginable
non seulement c'était un univers confiné
bruyant exigu mais en plus la vision
très restreinte rendait très difficile
le repérage des cibles et l'autodéfense
de l'engin contre les équipes anti char
le char étant totalement fermés il était
extrêmement difficile de voir quoi que
ce soit spécialement pour le conducteur
qui n'avait qu'un champ de vision très
bas et ne voyait que peu de chose
indiquait lui fallait s'en remettre au
chef de char situé plus haut dans la
tourelle et non la vision s'étendait sur
360 degrés il pouvait ainsi le prévenir
de tout danger aux alentours pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale les équipes anti
char était entraîné à s'approcher très
près des chars pour frapper à coup sûr à
l'occasion il pouvait même grimper sur
les engins ils posaient des mines
antichars ou jeter des grenades à
travers les tuyaux d'échappement ou les
trappes restée ouverte
comme il était conçu pour tirer à longue
distance le canon principal du char et
est inutilisable en combat rapproché
pour éliminer les fantassins qui se
rapprochait du véhicule les chars furent
équipés de lances grenades qui pouvait
être actionnés de l'intérieur
pourtant les équipes anti char
réussissez fréquemment à grimper sur les
véhicules dans ces circonstances
l'équipage du char visé devait soit
sortir de l'habitacle pour engager le
combat avec des armes légères soit
compter sur l'infanterie qui
l'accompagnent en protection ou sur les
armes légères des autres chats pour
qu'il la rose de tirs de mitrailleuses
afin d'éliminer les fantassins ennemis
grimpé à son bord
la tourelle du char et comme un
blockhaus mobile avec des ouvertures
réduite au minimum pour les armes
le blindage apporte une protection mais
limitent sérieusement la visibilité
pour les situations désespérées il y
avait une petite ouverture appelé
meurtrière à pistolet il existe
plusieurs manières de se défendre en
premier lieu si l'infanterie est assez
folle pour venir de face s'il suffit de
lui rouler dessus avec les chemises donc
les fantassins devait normalement
arriver de l'ariège ou sur les côtés
mais la meurtrière a pistolet était là
pour les contrer il suffisait de pousser
les coûts type rouvrir la meurtrière
face et le pistolet ou le pistolet
mitrailleur à travers et ouvrir le feu
pour les garder à distance
bien sûr les premiers chars russes
avaient tous une meurtrière à pistolet à
l'arrière pour contrer l'infanterie en
approche par derrière
les chars de toutes les nations avaient
tendance à être armés j'ai au moins une
ou deux mitrailleuses pour l'autodéfense
sexe certains chars n'en comptait pas
moins de six mais en plus des lances
pour de fumigènes permettant de dresser
des écrans de fumées des dispositifs de
minage des lance-grenades et même des
mortiers légers peuvent être montés sur
ses chars pour leur autodéfense en
combat rapproché ou pour contrer les
équipes anti char
j'aime juste les allemands utilisé un
ciment appelé immérité pour recouvrir
les flancs des véhicules afin d'empêcher
les mines magnétiques de se fixer sur la
coque
à plus longue portée d'autres danger
existait des canons antichars embusqués
représentaient la plus grande menace
un coup bien placé pouvait réduire un
char en pièces ses canons étaient
difficiles à repérer pouvait se
camoufler très facilement
pour fournir aux chars une protection
contre les canons anti chars ennemis
il fallait le plus de blindage possible
idéalement chaque centimètre devait être
recouvert d'une épaisse plaques d'acier
malgré tout l'équipage devait conserver
une visibilité hors du char et c'est
pourquoi furent prévu les trappes et
vitrages
les moteurs nécessitait des voix
d'échappement et d'alimentation en air
ces pièces faiblement blindée du char
présentait son talon d'achille et lé
point de viser favori des canons
antichars en embuscade depuis
l'intérieur d'un char les canons
antichars était pratiquement impossible
à détecter avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
alors que la guerre avant c'est le
calibrer la puissance de ces armes
anti-char augmenta passant du
relativement faible 37 mm présenté ici
et qui fut utilisée durant les premières
années de la guerre à l'incroyable
puissance du canon de 88 mm à haute
vitesse initiale
le 88 fut conçu à l'origine pour la
défense anti-aérienne pour laquelle il
fallait généré beaucoup de puissance de
tir pour envoyer un lourd au but en
altitude
lorsque l'infanterie allemande découvrit
que ce puissant canon pouvait aussi être
utilisé en tir tendu contre des chars
une nouvelle arme dévastatrice et enée
la vitesse de ces obus perforant ce mal
à mort parmi des milliers de chars
russes et allié de 1939 à 1945
les canons de 88 allemand que nous
voyons ici sont globalement conçus comme
des canons antiaériens et lors des
premiers jours de la guerre ils se
montrèrent très efficace contre des
cibles terrestres tels que les chars des
organes de visée directe fut rajouté et
plusieurs autres modifications donnèrent
naissance au plus efficace canon de char
et anti char qui fut jamais créé
tout au long de la guerre
le 88 fut l'armée la plus redoutée de
tous les temps tistes désarmé ali le
seul inconvénient de cette arme
incroyable résidait dans son poids très
élevé qui exigeait de le faire tracter
jusqu'à sa position de tir mais une fois
déployé camoufler il devenait une menace
mortelle
les canons antichars n'était qu'un des
nombreux risques que les tankistes
affronter chaque jour
alors que la guerre avançait les deux
camps développeurs des armes antichars
portable légère d'une puissance sans
cesse en augmentation les alliés avaient
le bazooka
alors que les allemands possédait les
mortels pointe à faust et panda shrek
ces armes seulement efficace à des
distances relativement courte donnait
aux équipes d'infanterie une capacité de
lutte antichar ce qui rendait vulnérable
même les chars les plus lourds ces
soldats allemands sont à la recherche de
chars alliés dans un village français
ils sont prêts à engager leurs cibles
avec un panzer faust il laisse passer le
char de tête avant de soigneusement
choisir leur cible
le char et détruit un énorme
investissement en ingéniérie en temps et
en matériaux pouvait alors être réduit
en cendres par un seul soldat doté d'une
arme simple
les armes d'infanterie anti xa
fonctionner sur le principe simple de la
charge creuse conçu pour fondre à
travers le blindage des chars et
exploser à l'intérieur du véhicule
pour contrer ces armes les allemands
découvrir que des jupes d'acier absorber
l'énergie du projectile pendant la
pénétration du blindage protégeant ainsi
l'engin
les chats prenait alors une apparence
grossière mais ses jupes étaient
efficaces et de vaart un équipement
standard pour tous les engins à partir
de 1943
de nombreux véhicules allemands en
particulier à la fin de la guerre
lorsque des chats rallier beaucoup plus
puissants apparurent été dotée d'un sur
blindage léger appelé sur d'hommes
représentaient le double avantage de
dévier les obus perforant et surtout de
dédier l'énergie d'une charge creuse
ceci n'avait pas une grande vitesse donc
s'il percer un trou dans une couche de
blindage située à l'extérieur de la
coque
cela fournit c'est une très bonne
protection pour l'intérieur
l'équipage de cinq hommes étaient le
standard pour tous les champs moyens et
lourds de l'armée allemande
l'équipage du tigre était composée d'un
chef de char qui était en charge du
véhicule et de la sélection des cibles
il servait aussi la mitrailleuse de
tourelles
ensuite venait le tireur qui était assis
près du chef de char et engageait les
cibles à travers ses optiques de tir il
était le membre d'équipage le plus vital
au combat chaque coup devait porter
la trajectoire d'un obus est affecté par
divers paramètres comme la direction du
vent la pluie la neige et d'autres
données atmosphériques
le tireur devait prendre en compte la
distance de la cible
les facteurs climatiques et compenser la
vitesse de déplacement des cibles en
mouvement qui étaient plus difficiles à
toucher un raté pouvait permettre aux
chars ennemis de tirer un coup fatal
seulement la mort lors des impitoyables
duel de chars de la seconde guerre
mondiale la manoeuvre du canon principal
de 88 mm du tigre résulte est vraiment
d'un travail d'équipé que ce que tous
les membres des piégeages du tigre
devait mettre à profit leurs moyens
d'observation pour identifier les cibles
potentielles et les indiqué au chef de
char un mot ce dernier désigné alors les
cibles selon les priorités et donnait
les ordres pour les engager le tireur
réglait la tourelle du tigre avec un
système hydraulique contrôlé par une
[__] et ajustait sa visée avec le
canon grâce à des binoculaire
grossissant il procédait ensuite à la
mise à feu grâce un système électrique
la différence entre les canons de chars
de la seconde guerre mondiale et ceux
d'aujourd'hui réside dans les systèmes
de stabilisation actuelle qui permettent
de faire feu pendant que l'on roule les
canons de l'époque ne permettait pas
cela il fallait arrêter le char ce qui
le rendait vulnérable pendant le temps
pour l'équipage de charger le canon et
de tirer
placé de l'autre côté de la tourelle à
l'opposé du tireur se trouvait le
pourvoyeur il avait une tache physique
celle de charger le canon le pourvoyeur
devait choisir le bon type de munitions
dans les casiers de stockage qui faisait
partie de la structure du tigre est
opéré un système de chargement
automatique ou semi automatique pour
charger le canin après chaque engagement
il avait aussi le laborieux travail de
vider les douilles et de
réapprovisionner le char avec les
énormes au but du canon principal
à l'intérieur du compartiment vers
l'avant du véhicule étaient assis le
pilote
sur sa droite se trouve l opérateur
radio qui remplissait le rôle vital de
gérer les communications radio et
servait également une mitrailleuse
la pratique habituelle était de peindre
un rond blanc autour du canon pour
touchard ennemi détruit
certains équipages l'été si efficace
qu'il leur fallait peindre un rond plus
large représentant 10 victoires
les chefs de charles est plus doux et
arborer leur série de cercle blanc fiers
comme des paons
le bruit à l'intérieur du char en la
communication très difficile échanger
avec les autres véhicules était presque
impossible
les ingénieurs allemands résolurent le
problème avec un système
d'intercommunication reliant les membres
d'équipage
grâce à un ensemble d'écouteurs et de
micros
la pratique de l'époque était d'utiliser
un largo phone composé de deux petits
micros placés contre la gorge sur
lesquels ont appuyé à chaque fois que
l'on voulait parler au reste de
l'équipage
s'ils ont enclenché la radio en même
temps le message passé au reste de
l'unité
le casque avec une paire d'écouteurs ce
qui étouffe et un peu plus le bruit du
moteur qui était de toute façon un
vacarme très fort
pour les communications entre chars tous
les engins allemands étaient équipés de
radio
dans les premières années de la guerre
les tankistes russe ne disposait pas de
tel raffinement technique dans le thé 34
étrangement aussi bons qu'ils étaient ce
char même à ses débuts les
communications étaient très mauvaises
car il n'y avait pas de radio ce qui
était la manière normale de procéder sur
les premiers modèles de t 34
le chef de char devait sortir de la
tourelle par la rsr des signaux à l'aide
de deux drapeaux un rouge et un verre
comme on le faisait sur les bateaux en
haute mer c'est ainsi qu'il changeait de
direction ou accomplissait diverses
manoeuvres ce qui était très
rudimentaire et peu efficace c'est bien
plus tard que comme sur le char situe
derrière moi 21 34 85 le plus gros
apparurent de véritables équipements
radio et d'intercommunication leur
avance en matière de transmission
donnait un sérieux avantage aux
allemands ce qui compensait le renne
infériorité en termes de blindage la
plupart des chars allemands débutèrent
la seconde guerre mondiale avec un
désavantage
le petit canon de 37 mm fut conçu
initialement pour équiper les panzers
trois qui étaient alors les chars
standard de l'armée allemande
le même canon de 37 mm arm est également
les panzers 38 et d'origine tchèque qui
étaient les plus nombreux au sein de
l'armée allemande
ces canons n'était pas assez puissant
pour perforer les blindages au delà des
courtes distances et même les canons de
50 mm présent sur les panzers 3
améliorer n'était pas non plus assez
efficace
seul le canon de 75 mm du panzer 4 et
des bataillons de storm cat schulz était
réellement adaptés à la demande du champ
de bataille moderne
bien qu'il ait aussi eu ses limites
même s'il était efficace contre le
faible blindage des chars du début de la
guerre le canon court du 75 mm ne
permettait pas aux au but d'atteindre
une vitesse suffisante pour pénétrer les
nouveaux blindés russes déployées en
téthys et des forêts à son époque le t34
était de loin le meilleur char que le
monde ait jamais vu
il était sur la plus haute marche du
podium sa forme perdure encore
aujourd'hui il est à l'origine de la
conception de tous les chars modernes il
était bon sur tous les aspects le canon
le blindage la vitesse en un mot sur
tout
pour compenser la mauvaise qualité de
leurs canons les allemands poussèrent
leur avance technologique en
introduisant des chars spéciaux de
commandement dont les canons avaient été
retirés pour faire de la place à des
équipements radio supplémentaires les
chars de commandement sont des
conversions fait en usine ou sur le
terrain de chasse standard est utilisé
par des chefs d'escadron de compagnie de
bataillon ou deux régiments relativement
expérimenté pour observer et coordonner
les actions de leurs subordonnés sur le
terrain dans ce but les chars de
commandement en portent généralement des
équipements radio supplémentaires voire
des opérateurs radio supplémentaires
certains des équipements d'origine
devait donc être retirée du chat
généralement ce sont le qu'annonce
principal et les soutes à munitions qui
prennent le plus de places en risque
évidemment retirer l'un ou l'autre en
particulier le premier est un
inconvénient considérable pour un char
de commandement sur le champ de bataille
la cohésion qui découlait d'une chaîne
de commandement fluide est l une des
raisons évidentes pour lesquels les
chars allemands de 1941 et 1942 réussir
à vaincre les t34 etc avait un
malgré leur infériorité technique
ces chars de commandement attirer
l'attention et des tentatives de
camouflage à l'aide de faux canon furent
utilisés et un char de commandement est
fréquemment dépourvu de son piano note
c'est pourquoi il fallait le faire
ressembler un peu un char normale avec
un tronc d'arbre ou un tuyau même
lorsqu'un feu aux canons étaient
présents sur les antennes
supplémentaires installées sur le char
pour faire fonctionner les équipements
radio efficacement et est un autre moyen
pour l'ennemi d'identifier et de
détruire les chars de commandement
ce facteur déconcertant n'étaient pas
prises en compte par la régie doctrine
allemande qui voulait que les chars soit
identifiée par série de nombres le char
de commandement arborant un gros chiffre
001 proéminent sur la tourelle une belle
invitation pour les tireurs et demi
en 1943 être dans un véhicule de
commandement n'était pas une place
enviable
depuis le temps l'infanterie avait
développé de nouvelles armes de
destruction de charges telles que les
mines magnétiques les bazookas et les
panzerfaust ces armes mortelles pouvait
tout détruire à travers le blindage d'un
char mais le russe découvrir que la
simple mise à feu d'une bouteille
d'essence lancé sur un bloc moteur
pouvait immobilisé les plus gros char
leur équipe anti char de voir bientôt
adeptes de ce moyen simple et improvisée
de destruction de chars
les chars que les russes chasser avec
tant d'efficacité était conçu pour
remplir deux rôles sur le champ de
bataille
le premier était d'engager de détruire
d'autres chars
le second était d'attaquer l'infanterie
et l'artillerie est nul
par définition réussir l'engagement et
la destruction des chars ennemis
relevait de la simple application de la
force brute
la physique élémentaire non dit que la
force est égale à la masse multipliée
par la vitesse pour détruire les autres
charles charles devait être capable de
tirer le plus gros obus possible à des
vitesses élevées cela produisait assez
d'énergie pour perforer le blindage des
chars ennemis
la puissance explosive en elle même
avait peu de valeur face à l'épais
blindage d'un char
ce qui donnait aux projectiles son
pouvoir de pénétration était son
incroyable vélocité qui frappe à travers
le blindage des véhicules ennemis
les obus perforant était simplement
conçus comme des objets solides
j'entends par là qu'un obus est
essentiellement du métal avec une pleine
charge explosive dont la haute vélocité
permet de dégager une pression et une
chaleur énorme lors de l'impact contre
le blindage faisant fondre celui ci afin
de le perforer pour dévaster l'intérieur
du compartiment ou de la tourelle et de
tuer leurs occupants
très occasionnellement il arrivait que
les obus perforant vol si vite qu ils
perforaient les champs et demi de part
en part sans endommager ni le véhicule
ni son équipage
par conséquent une gamme de bus antichar
explosif fut mise au point afin de
pénétrer le blindage du char et demi en
premier lieu avant d'exploser à
l'intérieur du véhicule
l'équilibrage entre les deux ne fut
jamais atteint en pratique et l'on peut
débattre pour savoir si une petite
charge explosive contenues dans les obus
et plus efficaces que les normes énergie
cinétique développé par un obus à haute
vélocité
contre l'infanterie et les canons
d'artillerie les charges devaient être
capables de tirer un obus explosifs
ici la vitesse du projectile est moins
importante ce qui compte c'est la
puissance de la charge explosive plus
gros lots but plus importante et
l'explosion
pour frapper derrière les murs et
détruire les obstacles une trajectoire
courbe est la meilleure méthode pour
contrer l'infanterie qui se cache
derrière les obstacles dans les
bâtiments et dans les tranchées en
général ces obus ont une pointe creuse
renfermant un explosif dont le but est
de projeter des éclats mortel qui sont
particulièrement efficaces contre
l'infanterie à découvert sur les obus
explosifs sont utiles pour détruire les
cibles non blindée grâce à leur
puissance
l'espace occupé par le canon l'équipage
et les moteurs laisse bizarrement peu de
place dans le compartiment pour le
stockage des munitions pourtant
indispensable pour survivre sur le champ
de bataille la plupart des sharks
pouvaient emporter environ 90 coup
soigneusement rangés dans le moindre
espace disponible
la plupart des chefs de chats remportait
de préférence un mélange de 40% de bus
explosif et 60% de bus perforant ce qui
était plus une question d'estimation
personnel du type de cibles susceptibles
d'être engagés lors de la mission
trouver la bonne répartition était une
décision cruciale
les obus perforant était inutile contre
l'infanterie et les obus explosifs ne
pourraient pénétrer le blindage des
chats avoir un stock important d'une
munition inadaptée rendait le char
inutile
ces artilleurs antichar tentent de
déloger l'infanterie d'un bâtiment sans
recourir aux obus explosifs
au ralenti on peut voir la trajectoire
rectiligne et la grande vitesse de
l'obuts avec un effet réduit sur le
bâtiment
un obus explosifs auraient été
dévastateur
au combat beaucoup d'équipages
expérimentés étaient capables de tirer
un obus toutes les cinq secondes
évidemment à ce rythme les réserves de
munitions s'épuisent rapidement rendant
le char impuissant
à ce moment délicat le chef de char
devait faire un choix crucial soit
quitter le champ de bataille pour
recharger et refaire le plein de
carburant soit tendre
l'approvisionnement sur le terrain
les munitions des chars ne pouvaient
être transportées à pied nécessitait des
véhicules de réapprovisionnement
les camions étaient trop vulnérable pour
être envoyé dans une zone de combat
alors les allemands développèrent un
char spécial dépourvu de tourelles
baptisé munitions ch l'epr afin
d'assurer la mission dangereuse de
l'approvisionnement munitions sur le
terrain pour s'assurer que les munitions
étaient utilisées intelligemment les
chars allemands n'avaient pas le droit
de tirer en mouvement
la doctrine stipulait d'engager
seulement les cibles ennemies depuis une
position statique
ce qui facilitait grandement la visée
augmentant les chances du tireur
lorsqu'il alignait sa cible dans le
petit triangle de son viseur
pour l'aider à estimer la balistique de
ces obus ceux ci étaient dotées d'un
dispositif de traçage qui produisait une
traînée lumineuse pour aider à suivre la
trajectoire du projectile pendant le
temps de vol vers la cible
les équipages priait pour faire mouche
au premier tir transformant le véhicule
ennemi en une masse incandescente
alors que le carburant et les munitions
exploser
un coup manqué pouvait signifier leur
propre destruction par un tir de riposte
la perspective d'une mort affreuse pour
les hommes coincés dans un char en
flammes
quand elle est en piste c'était une
vision cauchemardesque qui les
poursuivait en permanence
dans toutes les grandes batailles de
chars de la seconde guerre mondiale de
la pologne à l'afrique du nord et en
russie
les colonnes de fumée noire des
véhicules en flammes étaient visibles
sur l'horizon se rejoignent un comme un
nuage de tentes est bien trop souvent il
signait la mort de leur équipage
infortunés
la mort où les blessures menaçait les
équipages de chat pour de multiples
raisons
il n'était pas toujours nécessaire
d'endommager le véhicule un autre danger
omniprésent pour les équipages de chars
étaient les éclats d'obus causés par les
impacts à l'extérieur du char
alors que la vélocité externe de
l'impact était transformée en une
violente énergie interne
ces fragments mortels traverse l
intérieur de la tourelle où ils
tranchaient les corps des membres
d'équipage
entassés les uns sur les autres dans
leur monde clos un autre danger guettait
de nombreux modèles de chars comme le 38
et tchèques en service dans l'armée
allemande au début de la guerre les
rives est utilisé dans la construction
de ces chars étaient particulièrement
dangereux la violence d'un impact sur
l'extérieur du char faisait sauter les
têtes des rivets interne transformant
ceci en projectile mortel ricochant à
l'intérieur du véhicule
c'était également un problème majeur
pour les chats britannique du début de
la guerre qui était aussi construit à
base de riz vais plutôt qu en acier
soudé et de nombreuses blessures
horribles furent causés par les rives
est projetée par des tirs qui n'avaient
même pas perforé le char
un autre danger moins spectaculaire mais
aussi mortelle était également toujours
menaçants pour les chars des mines
antichars pouvait être placé en grand
nombre pour défendre une position
ces mines supporter le poids d'un homme
sans exploser et une équipe de
fantassins pouvait passer dessus sans
s'en apercevoir
mais sous le poids d'un char elles
explosaient avec une force incroyable
bien que les chats refusent parfois
détruits par les mines il ne perdait
généralement qu'une chenille ce qui
obligeait l'équipage a quitté son engin
pour tenter de réparer sous le feu
ennemi c'est énorme chenilles de fonte
repérée et nettoyer un itinéraire de ses
mines et le travail des sections de sa
peur parfois cette tâche rituel était
négligée
lors de la vital bataille de koursk le
général heinz guderian inspecteurs des
troupes blindés de l'armée allemande à
cette époque on resta livide de rage
ces nouveaux chars tigre était passé à
travers des chants domine non détectée
le privant de beaucoup de ses meilleurs
chars fer de lance de son armée
immobilisé par une menace faciles à
anticiper et à neutraliser
alors que la guerre se poursuivaient
chaque blindés survivants des panzer
division allemande devint un engin d'une
valeur inestimable
les pertes augmentait et la guerre
ravageait les usines allemandes
pilonnaient jour et nuit par les
bombardiers alliés
elle ne pouvait plus approvisionné le
front un véhicule pour compenser ce qui
avait été détruit
bien que la production augmente d'année
en année les pertes augmenter encore
plus durant les cruciales année 43 et 44
mais de nombreux chars n'étaient ni
complètement mis en pièces ni brûler et
pouvait être réparée et renvoyé au front
pour les alliés qui disposait de réserve
illimitée en hommes et en matériel ce
souci était moins pressants mais pour
les allemands c'était un problème vital
ce fut une grande source de frustration
pour beaucoup de dentistes aux allemands
quittent l'air lui même place à la
production de nouveaux chars en priorité
devant le remplacement des pièces
détachées et des moteurs
dans de nombreux cas les vieux char
pouvait facilement être renvoyée au
front avec un ravitaillement régulier de
pièces détachées et de moteurs cela
aurait été bien plus facile et efficace
que de fabriquer et acheminé un char 9
est complet depuis l'allemagne
durant la guerre du désert les lignes de
ravitaillement de romain l'était encore
plus difficile à maintenir
il devint essentiel de pouvoir récupérer
autant de véhicules endommagés ou
détruits que possible
bien que cela fit aussi partie de la
stratégie britannique c'était un besoin
moins pressant pour la 8ème armés qui se
trouvaient comparativement mieux
approvisionné
le contrôle des champs de bataille après
les combats étaient vitales pour
rebelles
il permettait à l'afrika korps de
récupérer les machines allemandes et
alliées en même temps contrôler le champ
de bataille après un combat de chair est
vital pour chaque camp in chief
la raison majeure à cela est que la
plupart des véhicules mis hors de combat
sont récupérables
si vous avez un petit trou en plein
milieu de votre charge
il n'ya généralement plus rien à
l'intérieur mais le couramment il
manquait une chenille ou bien la
suspension était endommagé ce qui
empêchait le char de repartir la plupart
de ces chars étaient très facilement
réparable en seulement une demi heure de
travail en russie il devint également
crucial pour les allemands de conserver
le contrôle du terrain après un
engagement l'été 34 russe d'une
mécanique simple pouvait souvent être
récupérés
les équipages allemands comme ce signe
utilisait souvent au combat d'été 34
capturés
au cours de la guerre 40000 char t34 fut
refabriquée plus du double de la
capacité de l'industrie blindées
allemandes en 1943 en russie comme en
afrique du nord c'était devenu une
nécessité première pour les allemands
que de garder le contrôle du terrain car
il ne pouvait se permettre de perdre des
chars
compte tenu de l'énorme poids des chars
lourds de la fin de la guerre comme ses
tigres les chars immobilisé ne pouvait
souvent être tracté que par un autre
tigra le tracteur le plus lourd de
l'armée allemande était le f3 de 18
tonnes mais il fallait trois de ces
engins combiné pour réussir à tracter un
tigre et dans les affres du champ de
bataille
les tracteurs étaient très vulnérables
aux obus anti chars aux obus explosifs
et aux armes légères d'infanterie
traille les tigres qui ont pesé chacun
60 tonnes et qui était sujet toute une
série de pannes mécaniques et
électriques souffrait sûrement de
certains problèmes et n'a de plus il
était extrêmement cher et ne pouvait
être gaspillés à cause de cela il était
particulièrement important de récupérer
les tigres hors de combat at il existait
toute une série d'options disponibles
pour les bataillons de chars des ss et
de la wehrmacht qui servait sur tire la
plus évidente était d'utiliser leur char
pour tirer le char endommagé hors de la
zone dangereuse
le problème résidait dans la tendance à
causer des pannes électriques ou des
problèmes de transmission aux tigres
tracteur sinon des semis chemillé non
blindée pouvait être utilisé mais
malheureusement plusieurs de ces
derniers étaient nécessaires pour
tracter un seul tigre aller comme il
n'était pas blindée cela les rendait
vulnérable sur les champs de bataille
fernand ce qu'il fallait c'était un
blindé de récupération capable de
tracter seul un tigre et qui serait apte
à opérer en conditions de combat
encore une fois la solution au problème
fut de développer un véhicule spécialisé
dans la récupération
baptisé berg panzer ces machines étaient
dépourvues de tourelles remplacée par
une structure cubique en bois
elle était conçue pour tracter
rapidement les chars endommagées et les
ramener à hors de portée de l'ennemi
tous les chats remporter de gros câbles
de tractage prêt à être attaché un
véhicule de récupération ou un autre
char la plupart des chefs de chars ne
partait pas au combat sans leurs câbles
déjà mis en place juste au cas où
les chars semble incroyablement robuste
et pourtant restent étrangement
vulnérables ils exigent une maintenance
importante et sont enclins aux pannes
ils cassent leurs chenilles avec une
curieuse régularité tout spécialement
sur de la boue épaisse en franchissant
des obstacles des champs de mines ou
encore après avoir subi des tirs de
canons antichars
les chenilles comme vous pouvez le
deviner sont la partie la plus
importante du char à entretenir
soigneusement et si le moindre
connecteurs le moindre maillon vient à
se briser c'est tout lâche ni qui
devient inopérante l'ennemi s'en prend
souvent aux chenilles en tirant dedans
avec ces obus et il faut les changer
c'est un travail très dur qui demande
beaucoup d'efforts tout l'équipage est
mis à contribution
je n'ai jamais eu moi même le faire sous
le feu mais j'imagine ce que cela doit
être
sur ces images c'est antiste allemand se
précipitent pour remplacer de lourdes
chenilles en plein milieu d'un combat
c'était un exercice très courant
malgré tout les langes et le char était
le roi du champ de bataille dans les
grands découvert de l'afrique du nord et
de la russie
au cours des quatre premiers mois de la
guerre les allemands découvrir qu'il y
avait un environnement où les chars ne
devait pas être déployé à savoir les
zones habitées tels que les villes et
villages car il devenait extrêmement
vulnérable à l'infanterie en embuscade
et aux canons antichars
les allemands apprirent la leçon dé la
campagne de pologne de 1939 lors de la
bataille de varsovie mais en dépit de
toute leur expérience précédente
il répétait les mêmes erreurs à
stalingrad et en normandie
certains chefs continuèrent à faire
manoeuvrer des chars en ville jusqu'en
en 1944 ces chars allemands détruit
jonchent les rues de villers bocage
ils furent pris sous le feu des keep
antichar britannique embusqués lorsqu
ils s'engagèrent en ville rendu trop
sûrs d'eux après une série de victoires
dans la campagne environnante
on
cette page du guide de l'armée allemande
édité par les américains en 1945
illustre comment cet énorme gaffe tiger
stupidement déployés en ville fut
détruit par un simple cocktail molotov
lancé depuis une fenêtre surplombant sa
position directement dans une trappe
ouverte
mais les allemands ne furent pas les
seuls à souffrir même le plus redouté
des géants semble-t-il avait ses limites
dans le dernier mois de la guerre ce
soldat isolés se prépare à détruire un
chat russe
son sourire suggère l'audace et la
fierté ou peut-être n'est-ce que le
soulagement d'avoir survécu et l'espoir
que tout sera bientôt fini